after 14 years and more than 3000
episodes the Jeremy Kyle show has been
dumped and not before time this toxic
bullying freak show was the human form
of bear baiting which saw mentally and
intellectually challenged people paraded
across our TV screens a sport
the biggest tragedy here is that it's
taken the death of dad Steve diamond who
reportedly took his own life after
appearing on the show to end it in a
world that purports to care about mental
health issues and hate crimes why did
the millions who watch this show every
week feast on watching vulnerable
dysfunctional people being exploited and
humiliated how sick is it that we revel
in the horrors of people's broken sordid
lives and call it entertainment the
current show was cruel and Exploited
Earth and TV bosses just decided by
boasting about their fantastic aftercare
aftercare that wouldn't be needed if
Kyle hadn't dropped a bomb into people's
lives and wrecked them this show was out
of control others still are which is why
it has to stop Steve diamonds death have
to be the last in the name of ratings
and money yes I I don't know about
whether I would if I were the ITV boss
make a decision to cancel the show that
has magic sitting here in front of Carol
I certainly won't normal loss of the
show and I think everything you said is
accurate the only reason I say I don
know is I've never been in the position
where you have to make those sorts of
decisions but I mean look the way I look
at this is this show typifies this one
and certain shows from the US like Jerry
the Jerry Springer Show which I imagine
this was modeled on they typify for me
the kind of audience voyeurism of
everyone all of us enjoying the
spectacle of often some of the most
vulnerable communities in our country in
this case and invariably it has to be
said it is the case that these are white
working-class communities and these
shows perpetuate the stereotypes the
cliches and all of the vulnerabilities
that the middle class is like to sneer
at when it comes to the working-classes
and I think that actually these shows
are out of date
I I think that's where I feel most of it
you know I've worked around these shows
and I managed to stand in for Tricia
when she did it and and I see what
happens to the people to the guests on
the show you know on a show like this
we're all you know when I say pretty
smart don't laugh at me because I'm not
but we can all handle ourselves in a
debate type situation I think the people
on that show could not and I've been
there when I've seen guess wound about
being there when I see what they do and
you know people one of the bosses
excuses is that people go on these shows
willingly you know think about it these
guys are they're offered a fee they're
they're put up in a hotel for a night
they're given although the foods and
booze the food and booze they can manage
and then they're wheeled on the next day
and wound up before they go on and I I
do think it's I think it's exploitation
in its purest form when you say you've
been there I'm just really curious have
you actually been there when they
filming or have you seen it and and what
did you think about the whole experience
I thought I saw what they did to get the
reaction that they want because I've
read producers who worked on the show
saying they were actually told to fire
it up and yes and kind of works up into
a state before they went on air and that
is true be that is true you know you
can't say that every single person is
doing that so it's just they have done
some good what some people some people
have been sent on courses and they've
beaten drug addiction some people have
been beaten now cook it's very easy for
us to sit around and there's a few
points majid these aren't working
classes most of these people aren't
working that's that's one of the points
sadly they probably live their lives on
benefit hold up just give me just I'm in
on soma class I think that's offensive
to the working class harm because they
actually go out and do a job they don't
sit around wearing tracksuits kind of
punch each other what fascinated me and
what I did on my radio show today as I
say we can all sit around isn't it awful
isn't it was a tremendous product of its
time it probably went too far these
things typically do but what fascinated
me and will you touched on this and I be
interested in you and indeed output why
are all the people who are shouting
you slept with my mother and we're going
to raise the baby or all right I
defeated in your fridge and I changed it
why they all white and that's what I
talked about on the way there Oh nearly
always white why do you think no because
I think possibly and it sickens me that
this government that is presiding over
the NHS in probably the most powerless
terrible problems with probation which
we're going to hear later today terrible
problems with kids stabbing each other
they have a parliamentary committee now
to investigate the production of reality
TV do they not realize and I have a by
the way a supporter of austerity
measures some of the policies they've
introduced have caused people to take
their lives or lose their lives
you've got pillars on the streets
because of the dams Judaism and now
they've got an inquiry into that but but
surely the thing about Kyle was the
extreme I think and over the years has
become more extreme if you look back to
the reality shows that long before Kyle
things like the time in the place
Anderson they were very responsible they
did it properly I said what's
interesting is we've all known kyle is
pushing it it was inevitable in the end
what's happened now was going to happen
the question is why didn't any of us say
anything about it well you were told it
what you saw it why didn't you say
something
I can't I did I mean I did it so many
years ago and I filmed it from the same
sudras as some of these shows came out
of but but I think the bottom line is
this this has been a problem for
long-term you said it was going to
happen back in 2008 there was a guest
appeared on the show a guy called coal
plaque and he was told that the baby he
thought was his wasn't a week later he
put a loaded air rifle to his wife's
head and actually went to prison for now
that that something should have been
done about the the the the tenor of the
show back then and it wasn't and as you
say Kyle over the years he's become this
snarling aggressive spitting person
who's two inches away from people's
faces these problems telling them that
there were but he shouldn't be a
performer certain answer your question
that you put to me I think I think that
among the many reasons you mentioned one
of them I think has is why the people
normally widely why they mainly white I
mean that's that was the endearing
impression I was left with and I used to
bunk off school and watch the show right
now so I think that it that one actually
what among the many reasons you
mentioned one of them is that I think
that it's the last demographic in this
country at whom it's acceptable to mock
and that's whether you call them working
classes or unemployed classes as you
know it's actually the last remaining
demographic you get over that feel
comfortable sneering at and I think it's
disgusting and can I just tell you some
things that have actually been said
about the show because you mentioned
Carroll cases that come out of
so in 2009 a judge said the Jeremy Kyle
show seems to have fed your insecurities
this is speaking to a man who attacked
his girlfriend after she failed a lie
detector test there there is plainly an
element of cruelty and exploitation in
what takes place then in 2007 a judge
said it is a human form of bear baiting
which goes onto the guise of
entertainment the people responsible for
this naming the producers should in my
opinion be in the dock with you and in
2014 this is Ofcom language the degree
of humiliation and distress displayed by
the guests exceeded the more typical
editorial content of the program I mean
I basically agree with everything that's
being said but Greg you know you said
that Jeremy calls the extreme it was the
most-watched thing on ITV daytime
program all night so these people know
because it's because they want it I
think you know I agree and I thought I
would like to see this conversation
broaden our other shows including love
Island I'm saying I think what Kostas do
because LaVon was mentioned we have to
we have to mention they said that we
will be delivering four-spoke training
to all future Islanders to include
social media and financial management
the key focus will be for us to no
longer be reliance on the Islanders
asking us for support but for us to
proactively check in with them on a
regular basis you to produce all the
judge talked about the producers and
it's convincing the people who worked on
this they are not people who are somehow
evil or good a job and year by year by
year by year that pushed it so there's
someone saying you know I mean you
understand they say to people listen to
what he's just said to you you're going
on a minute great you know better than I
and the numbers tick up so what are you
going to do you're gonna do more of it
so say we're writing the newspaper if
you put something whatever it shows on
the front page you sell more covers
broadcasters have already you know you
said that they encourage people are
there were reasons why people go on the
show there is a context right where if
you have a dick an addiction problem or
a mental health problem your your access
to public services is less than it used
to be you're targeting deliberately and
producers have spoken up this
deliberately targeting people in areas
where they don't have access to forms of
help I must forget their context this is
what ITV says about the producers the
production team the Jeremy Kyle show has
significant and detailed duty of care
processes
in place for contributors pre during a
post show which had been built up over
14 years after filming has ended all
guests are seen by a member of the guest
welfare team to ensure they're feeling
calm and emotionally settled before any
participant leaves to travel home and on
the ending of the show the CEO of ITV
Karen McCall says given the gravity of
recent events we've decided to end
production of the Jeremy Carl show the
Jeremy Kyle show has had a loyal
audience has been made by a dedicated
production team for 14 years but now is
the right time for the show to end
everyone at ITV's thoughts and
sympathies are with the family and
friends of Steve diamond the man who
took his life